hello and welcome to this talk from the
Yale Child Study Center program for
anxiety disorders I'm Ella Leibovitz and
in today's talk we'll look at what
anxiety is and how it commonly manifests
in children and adolescents we'll talk
about the common anxiety disorders and
how they're diagnosed and we'll discuss
just how prevalent these problems are in
the pediatric population in some
additional talks will discuss cognitive
behavioral therapy or CBT for childhood
anxiety disorders and look at keys to
successfully implementing CBT with
children suffering from an anxiety
disorder for example we'll take a look
at how to successfully plan and execute
exposures with a child suffering from
anxiety in another talk we'll discuss
the role that anxiety can play in the
family and the effect that it has on
parents and we'll talk about strategies
for parents to successfully support and
parent the child suffering from an
anxiety disorder so what is anxiety well
the term is used in many ways but
overall it refers to the response of an
individual to any situation or stimulus
that they perceive as a threat to
themselves there are four major
components to the anxious response the
physiological emotional cognitive and
behavioral aspects of anxiety and all of
these are likely to come into play when
a child is experiencing an anxious
response the emotion most commonly
associated with anxiety is of course
that of fear in fact fear is often used
as a synonym for anxiety but anxiety can
also impact other emotions a child
suffering from anxiety is also likely to
feel more anger and irritability perhaps
as a manifestation of the fite element
in flight-or-fight
additionally anxiety can impede the
experience and the expression of
positive emotions such as happiness or
enthusiasm and this contributes to
anxiety causing an emotion of the
emotional life of a child being rather
bleak some of them were dramatic
manifestations of anxiety are associated
with the physiological symptoms that a
child experiences when undergoing
anxiety children experiencing anxiety
will display both acute short-term
physiological signs of arousal such as
increased heart rate rapid breathing
dizziness and lightheadedness but
they'll also likely experience and
display more chronic and ongoing signs
of stress and anxiety such as recurrent
abdominal pain headaches and various
impacts of loss of sleep another effect
that anxiety has on an individual is in
shaping thought patterns and this is the
cognitive aspect of anxiety children
experiencing anxiety will likely have
many scarier scenarios running through
their minds and they're likely to
interpret even relatively neutral cues
as signaling threat children who are
experiencing anxiety are also likely to
display a kind of tunnel vision that
keeps them narrowly focused on whatever
it is that trigger triggering the
anxiety this isn't an accident but
rather it's a healthy and adaptive
aspect of the anxious response that's
useful when the trigger for the anxiety
is a real threat for example if I were
walking home from work one day I might
have any number of thoughts running
through my mind I might be thinking
about something I have to do later today
work I have to catch up on or maybe a
friend they'd like to see or even just
what I want to have for supper but if I
were to suddenly notice a truck about to
run me over all of those thoughts would
probably be vanished from my mind and
I'd be focused very narrowly on the
immediate threat of the truck and of
course this is a helpful and adaptive
response because I'm unlikely to do any
of those other things if I've been
smushed by a truck but for a child
suffering from an anxiety disorder the
world might seem full of trucks
constantly bearing down on them causing
them to experience anxiety all the time
and causing great interference to their
ability to focus their attention on any
of the other aspects of development such
as social life or school work another
cognitive effect of anxiety is the
tendency of children experience
an anxiety disorder to greatly
overestimate the probability of risk
primarily children will exaggerate the
likelihood of the situations that make
them anxious and that are the source of
the anxiety disorder so for example a
child with a fear of going to sleep at
night because of burglars the child who
thinks that burglars may come to the
house might estimate that the
probability of that happening is maybe
around 50% now obviously that's grossly
exaggerated because if that were the
case we'd expect the house to get broken
into every other night and of course
that doesn't happen but anxiety will
cause the child to overestimate the risk
in fact not only will the child
overestimate the risk that's the source
of the anxiety disorder but when anxious
children will also overestimate any risk
and will consider all negative events to
be more likely so that same child who
thinks that it's likely a burglar will
come to the house that night is also
likely to think that their that they'll
do badly on a test the next day or that
they'll get into some other negative
event again this can contribute to the
overall distress and impairment that's
caused by a chronic anxiety disorder in
a child the third aspect of anxiety is
that of behavior or rather the fourth
aspect of that of behavior and the
effect that anxiety has when a child's
behavioral patterns first and foremost
anxiety causes avoidance in other words
staying away from those situations that
trigger the anxiety again this is a
healthy and adaptive aspect of the
anxious response to keep us away from
things that pose risk but when a child
has an anxiety disorder and perceives
situations that are realistically not
harmful as being threatening avoidance
means that they don't have the
opportunity to learn that those
situations are actually quite safe so
for example a child who has a fear of
dogs will probably avoid any contact
with dogs and will be robbed if the
Opera
unity to learn that most dogs are
actually quite friendly or a little girl
who has a fear of elevators and walks up
the stairs might say to herself I'm safe
because I took the stairs but won't have
the opportunity to learn that she could
have been equally safe had she taken the
elevator sometimes avoidance seems like
the only way to lower anxiety once it's
already been triggered so for example a
child with persistent worry might engage
in a special kind of avoidance in
reassurance seeking a child might pass
their parents with never-ending
questions about their worries in order
to lower the anxiety that's triggered by
those thoughts when this happens the
child won't learn that if they don't
engage in that kind of avoidance anxiety
is likely to go away on its own learning
that lesson that anxiety will go away if
the child doesn't engage in avoidance is
a central part of cognitive behavioral
therapy for anxiety disorders but what
are some of the anxiety disorders that
are commonly diagnosed in children and
in adolescence specific phobias refer to
exaggerated and irrational fear of any
particular situation or stimulus these
commonly include fears of animals such
as dogs or snakes they can include other
situations like Heights or water or
darkness or they could include a fear of
needles or just about any other stimulus
can be the focus of a child's phobia
sometimes the phobia can easily be
related to a specific trigger in the
child's history such as the child who
has a fear of dogs and can date that to
the day that a dog bit them but in many
other cases there really isn't a clear
trigger for the phobia and it's usually
not helpful to invest too much energy in
treatment and trying to identify the
trigger that might have been the onset
of a child's phobia one special kind of
phobia is termed separation anxiety
disorder and this describes the child
who's filled with fear that's
operation from caretakers usually
parents children suffering from
separation anxiety disorder can become
very anxious even at very brief
separations such as being in another
room from their parents for a few
minutes a child with separation anxiety
is likely to imagine all kinds of awful
things that could happen to them when
the parents are away for example being
kidnapped or getting hurt many children
with separation anxiety disorder will
focus on negative things that could
happen to the parents when they're not
next to them for example getting into a
car accident or just disappearing and
never coming back
one other phobia is called social phobia
for sometimes social anxiety disorder
and this refers to a kind of extreme and
painful shyness that can cause a child
to avoid social interaction the child
with social phobia will usually imagine
negative outcomes of social interaction
such as making a fool of themselves by
saying something silly or making a
mistake and being laughed at sometimes
the avoidance will focus on specific
kinds of social interaction such as
speaking in front of class or talking on
the phone but sometimes it will be a
much broader array of interaction that
the child avoids leading to almost
complete self isolation and although
children will expend tremendous amounts
of effort in ensuring this isolation the
child with social anxiety disorder
doesn't necessarily suffer from a lack
of social awareness were even from a
real disinterest in social interaction
in fact many children with social phobia
actually fervently wish for friendship
and company even as they avoid social
interaction because of their fear a
feeling bad if they were to engage with
another person G a D or generalized
anxiety disorder could be characterized
as the child who has a kind of giant
antenna on their head finely tuned to
pick up just anything there is to worry
about children with generalized anxiety
disorder will usually move from one
worry to another but never feel relaxed
and
one day it might be an item on the news
that the child saw saying that
cellphones might cause cancer and then
the child could worry for weeks about
all the people in their family that used
cell phones and could get sick and died
another time the child might overhear
parents discussing the family's finances
and become tremendously worried that
they're all going to be homeless or if
they won't have enough money a child
with generalized anxiety disorder might
stay up all night doing and redoing
homework because it just doesn't seem
good enough and they're worried that
they won't do well in school and about
the outcomes that would have for their
life children with generalized anxiety
disorder will often engage in a lot of
reassurance seeking behavior and ask
their parents never-ending questions in
order to alleviate the distress caused
by the worry they'll often manifest a
lot of chronic physical symptoms such as
stomachache and backache and they'll
often have sleep disturbances as well
all of these symptoms together lead to
great overlap between generalized
anxiety disorder and symptoms of
depression one special kind of worry is
the kind diagnosed in OCD or obsessive
compulsive disorder children with
obsessive-compulsive disorder experience
a kind of intrusive thoughts worries
that come into their mind unwanted and
that they wish they could stop thinking
about but they just can't and they
usually have to perform special rituals
or repeated behaviors in order to
alleviate the distress caused by those
worries typical obsessions include
things like thinking about germs
contamination and sickness or thinking
about
awful things that could happen or even
terrible things that the child fears
they might do or already have done such
as hurting someone or even killing
someone parents are often tremendously
distressed that hearing that their child
has these thoughts but it's important to
keep in mind that having an obsession or
worry doesn't mean that the child
secretly wants to do those awful things
or even that they're particularly likely
to do them in fact it really just
reflects the child's desire to be good
and
not to do bad things and the fear that
they lose control over themselves
typical compulsions include things like
repeated checking behaviors such as
checking that the doors are locked or
the windows are shut
they might include washing rituals and
sometimes children will have to do
things in a specific number of times
such as tapping the table three times or
turning the lights on an or four times
many children also have compulsions that
relate to symmetry such as the need to
line things up on a shelf just so or
even to even out the two sides of the
body by touching with their left hand
something something that they touch with
their right in order to ensure a kind of
inner symmetry another anxiety disorder
in children and in adolescents as well
as adults because panic disorder panic
disorder is characterized by recurrent
panic attacks which are a horrible
experience in which it's as if a wire
trips in the child's brain and they're
just awash in tremendous waves of
anxiety with dramatic physical arousal
heart racing chest pain and rapid
breathing and usually accompanied by
dreadful cognitions such as the thought
this is the end I'm dying or I'm losing
my mind and going insane although panic
attacks will almost always subside
within around 15 or 20 minutes many
children will come away from the
experience with one thought which is I'm
never going to experience that again and
this can lead to symptoms of agoraphobia
or the avoidance of situations because
of fear of panic symptoms taken together
the anxiety disorders are probably the
most common disorders of childhood and
adolescence and probably of adulthood as
well studies have estimated that up to
one in three individuals is likely to
suffer from an anxiety disorder at some
point in their lives and most adults
will recollect that their symptoms
actually had their own set in relatively
early childhood maybe as many as 15
percent of children suffer from an
anxiety disorder and in a given time
many of those children however will go
undiagnosed and untreated for a long
time and this is particularly disturbing
given two pieces of information that
have gotten considerable support over
the past years from research into
anxiety we can think of these as the
good news and the bad news of child and
anxiety disorders the bad news about
anxiety is that it doesn't tend to go
away if left untreated of course all
children will experience transient fears
and age-appropriate fears that will come
and go as they develop but when an
anxiety disorder has taken root in a
child's life and has become persistent
source of distress or something that
interferes with the child's ability to
function in an age-appropriate way that
anxiety disorder is unlikely to just
disappear if action isn't taken to help
the child to overcome the fear this is
likely because the ongoing avoidance
ensures that the child never has the
opportunity to learn that their anxiety
is unbaked in reality the good news
about anxiety is that in the multitude
of studies that have looked at treatment
for childhood and adolescent anxiety
disorders including studies of both
medication and cognitive behavioral
therapy most children who participated
in those studies have actually improved
so that they were either cured of their
disorder or experience significant
improvement in their symptoms taken
together the fact that anxiety disorders
are not likely to go away on their own
but will often respond to treatment we
have a powerful argument for diagnosing
and treating anxiety disorders early on
in additional talks we'll look at what
goes in to treating childhood anxiety
disorders what is cognitive behavioral
therapy and how to implement it
successfully and we'll also look at the
role that anxiety plays in the families
and at how parents can successfully help
their children to overcome anxiety
disorders thank you